[Music]
uh hobo chili recipe five dollars why
does frozen asian look like a shady
gypsy traveler in a nice men's warehouse
suit is this a diversity higher no
that's not frozen asian no no that's
alex stein frozen asian we don't show
him because it'll sh it'll be a culture
shock with the squinty eyes and be nice
it's not a men's warehouse suit it's
joseph a bank only the best for prime
time 99 alex
no this is a that's a liz claiborne that
i got at a thrift store so you know it's
really nice dude i get them all at the
three i love the thrift store people
like oh she look nice i'm like i mean
some of my ties and suffer from maybe
dillard's or whatever the heck but dude
a lot of my sport coats are freaking
from the thrift store people it's like
so easy to look like this and the reason
why i dress it's like a costume almost
it's just easier to put this on than a
t-shirt that says like you know nwo or
whatever the hell you know it's almost
just like
brainless to put this [ __ ] on and it
makes me look a little nicer when i'm a
degenerate loser freakazoid so it kind
of helps you know it's like lipstick on
a pig yeah yeah yeah it's because you
want to look like [ __ ] you tucker
baby by the way
he's not wearing pants
you see that come on i don't have
anything gonna ask
dude
butt cheeks are all on this just
sweating he has sandals on his feet yeah
i got sand case yeah i guess i stuck
with some cats so i got the slides dude
yeah